the walking dead's 10th season finale
puts the spotlight on one of the show's
most notorious villains
negan and is full of surprises here's
how the episode plays out
and what it means the episode begins as
negan is exiled from the community he
helped save
he's given a cozy little house outside
of town and asked to not return
while dealing with this unexpected exile
negan has a vision of himself in the
past as a negan we meet at the end of
season six
the presence of this previous version of
himself implies that
while he's clearly changed a bit since
he was defeated and locked away
parts of his old self are still there
past negan chides present-day negan for
trying to win over the alexandrians by
playing nice
it's time to face the facts old man
you are nothing without her
the her here refers to lucille negan's
trusty baseball bat
but of course it also refers to lucille
negan's wife
and the namesake of the bat negan
appears disturbed by the vision but the
next day
he goes to the tree where he believes
his bat was buried after his showdown
with wreck in season 8.
this is when we get our first flashback
to 12 years in the past
negan is tied to a chair and the gang
leader called baxter is interrogating
him about
where he found his supply of chemo drugs
which is somewhat of a rarity in the
post-apocalypse
it's clear that this negan isn't the one
we've come to know later on
he's less self-assured has a hard time
killing walkers
and doesn't quite have that swagger that
has come to define his character
negan begins to tell the story of how he
got the chemo drugs
the drugs negan is carrying came from a
mobile medical clinic
in a flashback he makes a feeble attempt
to rob the clinic's ductus but someone
with a baseball bat quickly knocks him
out
eagle-eyed viewers will recognize his
attacker as laura who later becomes one
of his most trusted allies and the
saviors
when negan comes too he tells franklin
the head of the operation
the story of why he needs the drugs
which begins flashback number three
six weeks further into the past in the
early days of the outbreak
negan is living with his wife lucille
who's undergoing chemotherapy
negan is an attentive and loving husband
however they're quickly running out of
supplies and even though lucille only
has a few rounds of chemo left their
remaining stash of drugs
spoils drawing a fridge malfunction
forcing him to rob the medical clinic
when negan finishes telling his story
they're remarkably generous and kind to
him
they feed him and give him the drugs he
needs telling him they only want to help
people
negan seems genuinely moved by their
generosity thanks to these cascading
flashbacks
fans can finally see aspects of negan's
personality
that were buried in the years that
followed he's more vulnerable without
allies real weapons
or survival skills and it changes how he
interacts with the world
as negan is leading the clinic laura
gives him the familiar baseball bat
they'd previously used to knock him out
but there are even more flashbacks in
the midst of the scenes detailing
lucille's chemo troubles
were taken back to the earliest days of
the outbreak it also introduces a
different moment to negan's personal
growth pre-collapse negan as it turns
out
is a bit of a lout he loses his job as a
gym teacher after beating someone up
and he's spending his days playing video
games he's also cheating on lucille with
one of her friends
something that prevents him from being
with her when she first receives her
cancer diagnosis
it's pretty clear how much lucille's
cancer changed negan
or rather how much his love for lucille
changed him later negan weeps while
lucio recounts how she learned about his
affair
but she tells him that she forgives him
i want you to know that you made up for
it
the episode demonstrates just how
transformative those emotions
were for him during the earliest days of
the apocalypse so how did he then go on
to become the negan we know back in the
first flashback
negan is desperate to bring the chemo
drugs he's carrying back to lucille so
he gives up the location of the mobile
clinic
after the gang rounds up the doctors
they let negan go
lucille had previously begged negan to
forget trying to save her life
and instead just stay with her until she
died when he finally arrives back at
home with the drugs
negan discovers that he should have
listened to her lucille now a walker is
on the bed in their room
she appears to have purposefully
overdosed on pills and tied one arm to
the headboard to prevent her from later
attacking negan
written on the door is a harrowing
phrase please don't leave me like this
it's a crushing moment for negan who's
spent the entire apocalypse trying to
keep lucille alive
after sitting with her for a while he
goes outside to a nearby fence
and uses some barbed wire to put the
final touches on lucille the bat
once he said goodbye to lucille the
person he burns down the house
back at the gang hideout franklin is
being tortured for information
about where he gets his medical supplies
from negan puts us up to it by killing
most of the gang members but leaving
baxter alive
it's here where viewers get their first
glimpse of the negan they know
dressed in his signature leather jacket
and brandishing his bad lucille
negan tells baxter about the man he beat
up who got him fired
but now the rules have changed now
when i see red it's just the question of
what i
am capable of back in the present day
negan digs up lucille the bats and
brings it home to his cabin
he speaks to it as though as lucille
herself apologizing for leaving her
and even apologizing for naming his
baseball bats after her
negan then places lucille the bat into
his fireplace
and watches it burn but things aren't
quite that cut and dry
the next day negan strolls back into
alexandria when carol confronts him he
tells her that he's not interested in
living in exile
carol says that maggie will kill him if
he moves back and makes it clear that
now that she's tried to help negan
she won't intervene negan agrees and
continues on
looking at an infuriated maggie as he
walks by the mischievous grim he wears
while he observes her suggests that
negan's new chapter won't necessarily
include peacemaking based on how season
10 ends it feels inevitable that the
conflict between maggie and negan will
boil over very soon
and that it won't be pretty while
negan's pass reveals that he's a complex
character
and that his propensity for violence is
just one facet of his personality
it also demonstrates that violence is
something that has always existed within
him
even if it's hidden under the surface
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about the
walking dead are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one